>>> AN INFLUENTIAL CORONAVIRUS
SKEPTIC AND PUSHES A CONSPIRACY
THAT THE PANDEMIC WAS A PRETEXT
TO TAKE A DOWN THE U.S. IS ALSO
A LICENSED MEDICAL DOCTOR AND
INDICTED JANUARY 6th
INSURRECTION.
QUITE I RESUME.
NICK WATT HAS MORE.
>> Reporter: SHE WEARS A WHITE
COAT HE BUT NOT A FACE TASK,
STRUTS TO TED NUGENT TAOUP,
MAKING FALSE CLAIMS ABOUT THE
CORONAVIRUS.
.
>> ASYMPTOMATIC SPREAD IS NOT A
THING.
>> THEY ALL USE THE SPIKE
PROTEINS.
THEY ARE WHAT WE CALL
PATHOGENIC.
>> Reporter: THAT IS NOT TRUE
SAYS THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE TOLD
CNN.
BUT DR. SIMONE GOLD IS A
LICENSED EMERGENCY ROOM
PHYSICIAN.
SO PEOPLE LISTEN TO HER.
>> THERE ARE TWO HUGE IMPACTS
WHEN A DOCTOR LIES IN THE MIDDLE
OF A PLAGUE.
ONE, OTHER CRITICS, DOUBTERS
QUICKLY POINT OUT THAT THEY ARE
DOCTORS SUGGESTING THAT THEIR
OPINIONS ARE SOMEHOW MAINSTREAM
OR COMMON.
THE OTHER IS THEY HAVE TRUST ON
THE PART OF THE PUBLIC.
>> Reporter: AND THE CDC SAYS
THE UNVACCINATED ARE 11 TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO BE KILLED BY
COVID-19.
BUT DR. GOLD CLAIMS SHE'S SAVING
LIVES, LEADING A CIVIL RIGHTS
CRUSADE AGAINST VACCINE
MANDATES.
>> WITH THE TYRANNY OF MEDICAL
APARTHEID NIPPING AT OUR HEELS,
RISE UP, RISE UP, RISE UP.
YES!
>> Reporter: SHE ACTUALLY LIKENS
HERSELF TO SUSAN B. ANTHONY AND
ROSA PARKS.
AND JUST ROLLED UP TO A RALLY IN
SAN FRANCISCO LIKE A ROCK STAR
DRAPED IN THE FLAG, CLAIMING OUR
LEADERS ARE THE ONES LYING.
>> THE OTHER ONE THAT REALLY
HURT OUR COUNTRY WAS SAYING
MASKS WORK.
>> Reporter: GOLD CLAIMS SHE'S
BEEN CANCELED BY BIG AND SOCIAL
MEDIA.
WE CAUGHT UP WITH HER AT A RALLY
IN SAN FRANCISCO THIS WEEKEND.
>> DR. GOLD, NICK WITHOUT WITH
CNN.
CAN WE SPEAK TO YOU FOR A COUPLE
OF MINUTES.
>> Reporter: IT WAS HER SPEECH
FLANKED BY ASSOCIATES THAT
CATAPULTED GOLD TO FAME.
OR IN FAMY.
>> WE'RE HERE BECAUSE WE FEEL AS
THOUGH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE
NOT HEARD FROM ALL THE EXPERTISE
THAT'S OUT THERE.
>> Reporter: PRESIDENT TRUMP
RETWEETED THIS VIDEO WHICH
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES TOOK
DOWN, PROMOTING UNFOUNDED CURES
LIKE HYDROXYCHOLOROQUINE.
YOU CAN CONNECT TO A THIRD PARTY
THAT OFFERS A $90 TELEMEDICINE
CONSULTATION AND THE UNFOUNDED
MEDICINES FOR AN ADDITIONAL
PRICE.
PATIENTS WITH SYMPTOMS WILL BE
PRIORITIZED.
.
>> THAT IS PREYING ON PEOPLE
DESPERATE, TRYING TO SELL THEM
JUNK WHEN THEY'RE IN DIRE
STRAITS.
>> Reporter: NOW, GOLD HAS BEEN
ARRESTED AND INDICTED BUT FOR
THIS.
FILMED INSIDE THE CAPITOL DURING
THE JANUARY 6th INSURRECTION.
SHE PLEADED NOT GUILTY TO ALL
FIVE COUNTS, INCLUDING
DISORDERLY AND DISRUPTIVE
CONDUCT IN A RESTRICTED
BUILDING.
>> AT THE VERY LEAST, IT MEANS
THE GOVERNMENT CAN'T BE SAYING
IT'S SAFE AND EFFECTIVE.
S.
>> AS OF TODAY, GOLD IS STILL A
LICENSED DOCTOR HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE STATE'S MEDICAL BOARD CAN'T
SAY IF SHE'S UNDER INVESTIGATION
CITING CONFIDENTIALITY BUT TOLD
US PUBLICLY SPREADING FALSE
COVID-19 INFORMATION MAY BE
CONSIDERED UNPROFESSIONAL
CONDUCT AND COULD BE GROUNDS FOR
DISCIPLINARY ACTION.
>> I THINK PEOPLE WHO SPREAD
FALSE INFORMATION OR UNDERMINE
TRUST IN VACCINATION AT THE
PRESENT TIME ARE SPREADING
MISINFORMATION THAT IS DANGEROUS
AND COSTS LIVES.
AND I THINK THEIR LICENSES
SHOULD BE REVOKED.
>> WHAT AN INTERESTING LOOK.
AGAIN, A REMINDER THAT THERE WAS
AN ANTI VAX RALLY JUST DOWN THE
STREET FROM THE INSURRECTION
RALLY ON JANUARY 6th.
.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
AND, LOOK, SHE ALSO, AS WE HAVE
A PHOTO OF HER PARTICIPATING IN
THAT.
THERE SEEMS TO BE THIS SMALL
GROUP OF THESE DOCTORS OR W.H.O.
JUST SAYING WACKY, CRAZY LIES
ABOUT CORONAVIRUS.
AND YOU JUST HAVE TO WON